yo-yo back again this muhfucka quick
question
hit me brother sideboob yeah
are you a inside sideboob or an outside
sideboob kind of guy outside
why outside although inside is just like
how do i this is gonna come across awful
die just say it just say it
hmm cuz i'm always forward by it and it
does make a difference yeah inside and
outside make a difference means like i
don't know how k have a so outside here
outside when you see it mm-hmm and it's
got that curvature to it yeah it looks
like it's got weight yeah it looks like
it holds weight yeah that's a that's a
breast tip that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] tit
yeah inside ah
you know I hate what saggy inside
there's only gonna say saggy inside you
know when I come they wear a car don't
know what these things are called or
wherever but they're like they all set
their tits are separated so you can see
in like inside side mmm here but like
it's gotten a curvature to it and it
looks long like dog ears
yeah it looks long and it look you can
see exactly the depth you can see it so
it looks squish up mmm and long so they
look drained yeah malnourished yeah
that's why I don't like inside mmm what
do you like I don't know and then you've
got under as well
ah forgot about under certain underboob
is a different thing it's a different
thing bro you're asking for me to talk
to you you're asking for me to talk to
you hundred because Bedard the TE always
looks supple on the under boob always
looks supple bro always just that little
that little you bro curvature oh you
might know what you're doing cuz even
know what you do when you wear them
clothes yeah am i inside of my outside
I feel like a [ __ ] e outside because
I agree with the curvature thing you can
you can tell when it when the T is a
forty like it holds its weight mm-hmm
inside is the beta ball I like it
on some tees because a lot of time when
you see like side views nine times out
of ten they've got fake tits nine times
I what eight times out of ten they're
probably all fake tits and the ones I
have got real tits
I like the droopy tits and they're not
really that good-looking okay I mean but
you get that odd one or two that have
the perfect inside side boo hmm
and because obviously where I work like
I see so much tea every day mm-hmm and
I'm working a strip club but it's just
because the nature of our business
everyone dresses up so you see your love
see a lot of good outfits and it's just
it's mad it's mad but I didn't I didn't
even remember about the under boob under
who's Amanda boob is like a different
caliber under boobies [ __ ] me tonight
yeah unlikely for caliber okay yeah Bri
caliber and it's hey this is crazy
because this is that see everywhere you
know it's mad you know what's actually
mad this is how stupid man were at my
brain is right so I don't miss is like
the I'm attracted to the like allure of
nudity so yeah I don't want to go to
just be a snake yeah just stand in front
of me ask yeah that's not hot that's not
safe give me something to think a large
array yeah exactly yeah
but the extreme that I can still find
alluring is pathetic to the point where
like if she was her if she was ask naked
but had like a skittle on each I needs a
nipple that when a Rousey with it then
I'm horny and I'm not [ __ ]
or when they're naked and it's just
paint
this isn't painted and then ask naked
yeah this just painted yeah that's sexy
sexy sexy but if I see you just plain
Jane yeah naked obviously if we're
having sex as buff that every year but
like I'm just like no man I know what
you mean the idea of it is different
yeah the imagination yeah yeah yeah how
little imagination I require is that's
funny
that is funny but yeah I like that
tease our next Oh God
are you tits or ass man ass but you know
what mmm
I think I was actually gonna say this to
you party the other day mm-hmm
as I get older and more mature yeah I
feel like I'm not so objective about
body types anymore in that like I used
to think like me flat ask and do one mmm
to be fair flat ass can still do like
flat flat yeah good yeah yeah
flat for I can still do one but like I
used to be I used to be like it has to
be thick and like now I'd sometimes I
can just like now I feel like I can
admire the beauty in all of it barely in
it my off camera yeah yeah like now I
feel like I can truly appreciate all
sorts yeah yes a buffs limiting bike
even if she hasn't really got much tea
has much bag like yeah it's like there's
always some something obviously there's
certain but is that grotesque yeah but
there's always something yeah back up
hmm cuz I've I know exactly make the
older you get the more different kind of
people you [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
and I was saying I was saying this oh my
days it's crazy I'm saying is someone
the other day so in my head I've got a
paper type
yes but reality is that's probably not
my type anyway
I think it's my type but it's not so
context when I say paper type guys I
mean you write all the attributes down
in a piece of paper same guys and girls
as well save girls do for guys and guys
do for girls so obviously for me I would
say curvy nice smile nice eyes
nice teeth good personality buff beyond
belief nice I order these random generic
things that every guy would say come
here and it's crazy because nine times
out of ten you'll see so many buff
chicks on Instagram but when you go out
and blah blah blah and you will be
gassed if like you approached him and
[ __ ] started to pan out yeah but you're
only just because you know you want to
[ __ ] her or she knows you want oh you
want to [ __ ] him like you're a girl bro
right and only up until that point you
[ __ ] is when you actually discern me
whether you are my type or not because
once we've had sex and I feel like I've
had sex with my paper type I mean
actually that interested in you because
is there is there mortar just what I see
yes do not mean yeah but when you talk
about your reality type or say mr.
bellar like if I lined up all my types
and then lined up no mates at the end I
would never look at her hmm dude I mean
because she's not my paper type yeah
yeah but you're like severely attracted
I'm some but over a thing like there's a
thing like for me I always think like
yeah I was thought there was i sir doubt
tributes that if someone had that makes
me attracted to them so for back in the
day was like what I had the typical
mixed-race it's ringing curly hair
whatever they used to send me loopy yeah
but at the same time it wouldn't ever
make me find that person more attractive
than if they didn't have it
yeah dude I'm saying that so like if I
found someone say if I thought someone
was a five mm-hmm but they had that hair
that I like doesn't make him a six yeah
but in my head I'm still like are that
hair is a turn-on yeah but in reality is
genuinely not because they won I think I
bet I won't go without hair and to like
yeah my type I've actually gone for the
ones that I'm actually disgustingly
attracted to have none of the attributes
absorb yeah yeah for [ __ ] sake it's
because that
yeah yeah no no no no no no no no no
hang on sorry guys
what happened some technical
difficulties
no from that way Lucy that way I think
yeah sorry guys
yeah yeah yeah cool cool cool cool cool
cool
we're back I'm not getting out
yes time for minor and what we saying so
you've seen the types it's actually go
for yeah no types you attracted to so
the ones I've actually like been like
extremely attracted to they're not any
none of them on they don't I don't need
boxes to tick yeah if I'm attracted to
your my tractor to it doesn't matter why
should you have but I think it's safe to
say they're foreign looking [ __ ]
it's like baseline for me mmm foreign
look in I'm in mmm I mean yeah yeah love
the foreign looking [ __ ] oh you said
that everything is falling into place
now yeah yeah man I just love a bit
exotic mmm I do hear that video man and
puff nice if you're hot you're hot
yeah if you are hot you're that's true
that's so true it's an interesting take
mm-hmm guys let me know what you think
in terms of like reality your reality
type and a paper type is there a
difference do you think like that do you
feel like there is a difference because
I personally feel like there is due to
experience so I don't know you let me
know man through no mates on the pod
yeah so what you do it you letting it
fly loose buddy certain know about what
no misses one all right no no no I don't
mean about I don't mean about yeah did
you say no mates yeah I mean about you
being like yeah I know boot up I know
you can't with that you guys booed up
who has booed up i tix this guy I'm
gonna beat you out now now you said that
yeah I'm gonna pay you out this guy yeah
listen to this guy I'm as a Texas guy
yesterday yeah doesn't matter I text him
but
I fix him yeah and it made him laugh
instead of my mind six to me back like
lol hahaha or laugh emoji man said
hahaha we laugh we laughed a man said we
like their one entity gay he's cute man
you're a cute guy [ __ ] you I was very
cute you love love like who doesn't bro
yeah man loved up I like that man it's
been a minute speaking of not speaking
of but in similar context pet names so
yeah I feel like there's a fine line
between boo babe and baby in terms of
when you like the pet name you give
someone okay so I feel like the generic
is babe mm like hi babe oh that's the
generic standard but the one day you
call her baby or the one day she calls
you baby
it's not saying I love you yeah it's
real now it's real you can't go back
from can't go back is so weird
he's like oh I've had times with my
phone is autocorrected to baby and I've
had to back step and I've had to been
like I really sorry I didn't actually
call you babe ah that's why I have to
stick with a BBE mmm BBE because we
never auto yeah Manny went to baby and I
was cuz yeah literally baby is like I
love you yeah his [ __ ] it all love it
[ __ ] you baby I've had and I remember
I've had girls that I'm talking I'm just
talking stage and she's called me baby
mmm-hmm a number that nah this [ __ ] is
crazy come on crazy she's trying to
spiral it
you called him baby they wonder call him
um babe yeah man we haven't even eaten
pasta together and you are calling me
baby no wait it's also double-edged
sword because if it starts off as baby
just because of that's just what
happened that's just the first thing
what that was set as yes the babe or boo
it has to stay yeah you can't go back go
back yeah yeah we're at baby now where
baby we have to say this weird if I call
you babe or is weird of all you
sometimes babies long
prov baby every time I know I know and
sometimes that's long
I don't equal that baby have you oh all
the time so head down down all the time
that you yeah don't do boobs baby baby
baby I hate when people call me babes I
used to hate that when I I think in
college because obviously I went to I
don't know if I've mentioned it in his
pod I went to a boarding school for
college and obviously was a white area I
was near Brighton
they loved the word babes and I never
used to use it back that was like don't
[ __ ] call me babes it's so it was a
fat even rape yeah patronizing away in
there babes there are babes don't
[ __ ] call me baby call me baby I can
hate you now it's a second [ __ ] they
yeah you called everyone babes up of
everyone boobs
no but just context like I just say you
log on babes yeah mean as like a gesture
yeah babes is like friendzone and yeah
babes as friends call me babes with
voice what boys what come on babes
that's why I think I could cause I go
everyone dude in it yeah everyone dude
you do like what everyone dude
including females and females that I
like I've been talking to in the past or
seein or whatever and call them dude
they get so pissed off I don't [ __ ]
call me dude I'm not I've been calling
you dude shut up bro as well when cool
guys bro and you know I love you you're
calling me bro you know I love you bro
it's funny hilarious it's funny it's
always not is I don't know why they do
it they obviously do on purpose they do
all my games with these hoes ain't got
time it's all my games you know I love a
new cool bro baby that's [ __ ]
hilarious I don't want to cuff like that
again
that's funny bro and you know I love
that's hilarious
that's [ __ ] hilarious oh Jesus that's
funny the ear man
there's all my games dude dude is just
yeah don't get offended if I ever call
you do because that's just me and Sam
don't get any yeah if you're going
you're calling me babes though
trust me I'm about to get friended he
says friendzone and it's just general
I just feel about hun it depends on I
think it depends on a person and it
appends on whether you're saying it to
me or I'm reading it via what's up okay
because the word hun I don't really like
it per se but it could read well
sometimes and on how the conversation is
flowing mmm gin I mean it could be
banter Ahsan it could be like a nice on
yeah well I would never call someone on
oh I don't think guys cool girls honey
you know it's not for this it's just not
in my vernacular yeah yeah yeah yeah how
do you feel when they said to you it's a
rarity but I just bypass it because it's
pointless for me to address the fact
that don't like being called hon yeah
because if they like saying it I'm not
about to change them yeah it doesn't
really fair play it's just one of those
ones pet names you know yeah pet names
are there there's a low-key make or
break they can be low-key because like I
said if a Sunni to go from babes a baby
you can't go backwards
mm-hm and if you know I love you call me
bro you're getting punched something
thing is I'm just as bad sometimes I
like to [ __ ] around and then I'll take
it to another level if I know you love
me yeah I'm calling you bro I'm calling
you fam fat they might show you I'm
going yg
they hate fam you say I'll just get out
like a morning joke good morning mister
my G
why do you say what's the move today oh
they hate they look at their phone like
this piece of scum and I how dare you
you know I love you hilarious you know
what made me laugh the other day the one
I sent to you the the memed senti of the
day when the when the ting is doing this
to your head yeah yeah and she's your
and she said that's my best mate
when she's rubbing her fingers through
your hair and this is your best man is
my weakness weakness if the girl with
acrylics is just scratching up my back
my headpiece I'm sleeping in your arms
baby bro sleeping in your arms that's my
weakness be careful with that be careful
of that and they know it's my weakness
as well and it just flan it is not ha ha
they love playing games and of [ __ ] like
that
they love man loving them have you ever
been friend-zoned before
oh yeah for sure of course like every
guy has I know who friend-zoned you I
I'm not thinking of the person who I
think because I don't even [ __ ] y'all
thinking of I don't think I've pursued
that you did I didn't actively pursue
that you didn't actively pursue it he's
not you loved her of course I did and
she was your boy I know she was but she
knew I fancied her I knew I knew she
fancied me OK there was nothing that
could pan because of my situation okay
yeah yeah and I know that for a fact
just purely because of the way we used
to interact when ever we'd bump into
each other unlike nights are in blah
blah blah blah blah yeah I remember one
time we went to a common what club it
was it was all of us we went out I
hadn't seen him in a minute was probably
like Endor turn to new time kind of
thing we went out if I'm as soon as she
saw me she pushed man out the way to
come hug me again I remember that Bush
pushed over out the way like it was
nothing
I remember you you've told me that story
about nine times so I know if it felt
you in your chest not yeah of course I
felt I felt sweet mmm gore suppose we I
don't know if I've ever been
friend-zoned but I've been toyed with
chew-toy de Pham van Storch house Oh
Vance tell he was a lot of story time he
loved Pam story time he loved her story
time for these man
Vance tortures played me I hope you say
she's definitely she's definitely if I
hope she is she played me so you man
listening this is what she did so story
time it was his girl right
my name was Chelsea she used to work
Vance store hence Vance dojos advanced
watch else yeah I'd better name but
whatever I was in love with her I know I
was in love with her and she caught me
just on the back of a breakup and I was
infatuated with her and she was she was
moving to me as she was I thought I
thought she was boss he was both she is
but she is buff and she was cool math
she was she's just a girl that was just
wearing vans before girls were wearing
vans yeah this was years ago yeah she
was cool she was I was really cool and
so and she used to give man discount on
asthma all sorts and I would just buy
shoes for this just so I could see her
yeah I've spent 50 quid I couldn't
afford on shoes just so I can see her oh
it's awkward but she would always
message me and but I'd do you want to go
do this you want to do that you want to
do this and I'm like yeah yeah yeah
desperate little [ __ ] wrap at me yeah
yeah yeah we can do it Friday we can do
that and I'm running around like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and then she'd mess it you
always happen she messaged me on like a
Monday I do want to go cinema or like
Thursday and I'm like yeah calm
Wednesday would come [ __ ] or me I
haven't heard from orange juice day yeah
of course Wednesday would come we still
good to tomorrow yeah yeah Thursday
would come your babes just checking in
trying to not sound desperate
yeah base just checking in still good
for tonight there's a screening at 6:00
we could grab a Nando's beforehand if
you're feeling peckish
I was desperate to take this girl
[ __ ] desperate and she would air me
again
and then the day I died they would roll
around I'm stewing a higher yeah my
thumbs trembling over that delete
concert REM Ellen
I'm going into whatsapp to see if this
[ __ ] on I lied but I'm doing all
sorts I'm checking for that was before
you could get rid of blue ticks ah
that was before yeah no no no this was
blackberry days okay that's how long ago
it was yeah so I was looking for that ah
that red mm so I'm going into the chat
senior she's ready to see me she's ready
Friday would roll around typical aha
babe sorry [ __ ] uncle went into a
school and all this champion fam
I would melt again and I'm like fine
fine because I know that's fine bye that
routine continued for months until one
day she messaged me and she was in town
and she was like I'm just in town are
you about fam'ly got my shoes on a rant
attack I've got my [ __ ] shoes on a
rant
it's a [ __ ] town and we just walk
around town it's so gay I was so
overjoyed to be on somewhat date with
this girl so overjoyed we went into a
[ __ ] furniture shop and started
pretending to pick out furniture like
we're a married couple I was over the
moon I was over the [ __ ] moon I was
at this [ __ ] loves me she loves me man
I love her yeah we're finally on a date
and she's actually gonna see what she's
been missing this whole time which she's
been paying me off so we're doing all
this and then I'll go we go our separate
ways and then she pulls me around the
back at Nando's lips to me I remember
it's to me uh grab me and lips and I was
like [ __ ] we've made it yeah this is the
girl of my dreams we've made that we've
made it and then the patterns continued
yeah same thing went back home got the
solid lips next week right now I'm
chasing her yeah baby one you want to go
on a date see you
the shop shall play like we ain't been
texting and that continued continued
continued and they would talk talk talk
talk talk ah and then the one time I
remember she loved I knew she liked guys
with tattoos in it she was about tattoos
and so there's me and I'm like uh I'm
thinking about this is when I didn't
know it I wasn't really hitting gym
mother well I was but I was like what
1819 so I'm hitting gym trying to get
big and she's like I said I'm thinking
about getting a sleeve in it and she's
like don't get sleeve and I was that way
I don't think I know she likes leaves
yeah so don't talk me multiple times
yeah I know you like them I'm why she's
like your arms are too skinny or one
little bit I remember I screenshot is
sent to Erin I was like let's go gym now
so furious oh yeah and then the next
time I saw her she was on road with her
man oh yeah and I was like she's she's
had a hole she's developed a whole
relationship in the time that she's been
to toyomi around yeah I've never been so
heartbroken I've never forgiven that and
then for the years to come
years to come after that she would ad
hoc ad ad man on Ezra
yeah she'd ad hoc ad man on yo J sorry
yeah
yes only on Instagram should a dog admin
on Instagram follow and then I'd follow
her get vex about how well her life is
unfollow her and then it was back and
forth like nothing really for years Oh
mud yes so yeah I've never been friends
no but she [ __ ] me over
[ __ ] yeah man my heart was young and
feeble buff that's funny you can't do
that ladies you can't do that to guys
you just can't friends only as long as
well I don't know why people I don't
know why people friendzone other people
when you know when you know they love
you because I fast you find it a
turn-off so I'm saying mmm like I
wouldn't friendzone it go
mmm like if I know she's into me oh I'd
rather ask them not be boys at all no
because that it depends that depends
because I friendzone people at work okay
but that's because I have to because I
don't find you attractive hmm but I'm
not gonna be a dick and be like stop
whatever you're doing because I'm not
interested you know I mean I can't do
that so you have to I don't directly
friendzone them but they get the gist
yes they'll call do you know I mean I
know you mean but then for me it almost
feels like sometimes when I do that I
look at them and I think do you even
want to be my boy mmm you don't like you
just want us to have a thing yeah so
like I don't necessarily worst feel like
it's genuine yeah oh yeah oh [ __ ] you
know from who knows who [ __ ] knows
mm-hmm oh God so speaking of that sleeve
story yeah I was tell me so I was
thinking of embarrassing moments in my
life yeah to do with like girls and
breakups and all that's yeah yeah yeah
and I thought about like breakup like
the breakup situations that I've had and
some of them are so hilarious I was
thinking to Ryan him down
I did right up and that sleeping was in
there that just reminded me of him yeah
and I was thinking like there were some
times I was such a yeah yeah there was
one time jealous that's one time was a
girl see when I was like 16 yeah 17 you
know her 16s before I met you
yeah no but I know okay so um she oh she
toid me as well she [ __ ] played me as
well she check this out I was a little
[ __ ] oh she was seeing her ex at the
same time she was seeing me
mm-hmm I think but she was trying to
black it like she wasn't yeah I remember
stand there my boys were walking to
Sainsbury's one day we walk past his
house and I saw her car outside it
I like 9:00 p.m. okay on a school night
as well I was like [ __ ] sake and I must
a message to her about it and she's like
oh shut up I can like we're still
friends and all this yeah I was young
and naive then so I actually believed
that yeah what [ __ ] idiot anyway that
night I got so in my feels phone yeah
it's how long ago was I got so in my
fields I what did I do
I thought so my feels I wrote her a text
to break up with her it was long and
this is when I still needed like top-up
credit mmm and it caught it must have
cost me like 40 P tempio texts it was
pages he was pages and it was me like a
brother I was tasting it and I was like
I know like this isn't a special to you
as it is to me and like seeing your car
outside his house and how you treated me
when our boy ops you just made me
realize that maybe we're not on the same
way
and we want different things I'm gonna
something like I know there's gonna be a
lot of Tears at least from me anyway but
these times I've got tears running down
my face I've got tears running down my
face I hope we can still be friends but
yeah I can't put myself through this
anymore such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] and then as soon as
I send it so that it was confirmed I
took her out on my top friends on
MySpace
she was my number one top friend I'd
rape stir out so that it was confirmed
so the streets new so the streets new
I'm back on the market that's funny
and I sat there crying and I'd take some
one of my boys to come over
mmm and then though we just he came over
and we just embraced house I'd my yard
he homies I so good it's all good though
I buy it don't worry by 16/17 you know I
loved her oh I loved it for no good
reason for no good reason
yeah I was such a [ __ ] joke thus
funny fam is so embarrassing yeah those
are my yeah e days yes bro yeah man I've
had yeah T days I've had yeah t day
thought to me from so I'd remember 2016
stay to write yours
Matt's back in Norfolk your mum's they
went our and then my girl at the time
was on holiday here obviously it was the
thing was rocky from the whole situation
was Rocky I remember fam fam I drowned
my sorrows you did you did I drunk
alcohol that night was that the dying
you were sick on my porch so you say but
I don't remember it yeah I think that's
the time you fell down doorstep yeah
doorstep when I apparently laid there
for age I don't remember from I was
embarrassing and I bet it was I don't
remember
oh my days so embarrassing
yes it's crazy though because when you
get in your fields yeah it's hard Lisa
much but you think it's all sensible
yeah talking about in Phil's mmm story
time talking about in fields there's a
time when we were newly friends mmm but
now we were good friends but you're
still right within the first year six
months whatever and it's the first day I
am no no no no no no yes it was the
first day I cheat on someone okay and do
you remember now so this guy right this
what happened right so who you were out
and the girl that I know was out all are
having a good time Oh Larry's on a
Tuesday night in carries and where our
2x4 was having a good time and this girl
I know she was drunk as [ __ ] and she was
sticking it on man I had a girlfriend at
the time but this is when I didn't
understand I was young and naive I
didn't understand that basically if you
were in a relationship a girl tries on
with you you say sorry I've got go for a
girl and she leaves it yeah I didn't
understand that there was a second stage
with the super sleigh girls that when
you say sorry I've got a girlfriend and
they're like so I didn't understand I
was like existed Wow
what do I say now do I say you know yeah
and yes she was like so she's not here
and I'm like brav it was is that
forbidded again yeah and I was like [ __ ]
and then that's when you get inside your
own head yeah like she must think um
barfy she wants me to cheat yeah anyway
well I didn't even read I didn't even do
anything
Oh having a good time her friends are
chatting to my friends cetera cetera so
so I go take a seat and she climbs her
drunk ass on top of me and tries to kiss
me and I think she liked touched mmm
whatever and I'm like
I'm still scared before it it I'd never
cheat before I've assumed that was eyes
everywhere yeah and masses and then like
pushed I think I looked over at you and
you Lily you've seen a ghost
you look like you've seen a ghost and
you've stormed off out the club you look
like you and my girlfriend I'm just
caught me cheating and you're like I
can't believe you I can't believe who I
just saw
I can't believe I saw I couldn't he was
so upset with me I was so disappointed
it was the I start crying I was so upset
we were the couple we were the couple
and I was crying because I'd done you
wrong I cheated on you bro so
disappointing so disappointed and your
words often you like now you can't be my
friend you can't
like what did I just see like love and
then I was so drunk and confused and I
was crying and then Aaron comes along is
that what a [ __ ] you crying at a [ __ ] he
grab and then I [ __ ] me like a tap
stopped yeah was I I don't know and I
was 210 fine and I just couldn't believe
their shock and disappointment in you
that was hilarious
I remember I was hilarious I can
remember [ __ ] hell good days funny
ways they were funny days man funny
funny days oh Jesus
that was funny I forgot about that [ __ ]
you know we've got stories for days bro
100% I love story time [ __ ] love story
time those were the good old days when
they was going on ten years ago no yeah
that's crazy you've known each other
over a decade that's crazy yeah [ __ ]
over a decade bro mmm it's ridiculous
we're old we went out yesterday I felt
old a mother lied to you I'm not gonna
lie to you I felt ancient my father said
everyone was having a good time jumping
on tables and she and I was just there
with my jacket on tight I've been there
done that man I don't think I could do
clubs anymore bro I actually do here I
honestly don't think I could live like a
chilled white
brohoof or chilled web when we went to
schloss the other time she would busy
busy busy it's not Club
it was just not with no potentials just
chose I love that well lit I like to see
people now before I went to be dark I
went to see my victims I don't want you
to see my victims yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's why I want it now I want a well
lit mmm
I'm always [ __ ] I'm always [ __ ] us to
keep it yeah that's funny I don't know
what to do like do you ever feel like
you're gonna get to the point which is
like cuz obviously when when I come up
we always trying to make an event out of
it and stuff yeah do you ever think it's
just gonna get some points like it's
just yeah I think it will just let's
just chill chill let's just chill catch
bands and record a [ __ ] podcast and
it's gonna get to that stage soon yeah I
don't even think I'm gonna be sad about
it neither am i because there are days I
just I just can't be awesome times I
just can't be are sometimes but I feel
like it's obligated that's it I feel
like is obligated that is exactly it
it's crazy because obviously when I came
to yours
last month we didn't we didn't go out
did we just yeah yeah and it was fine I
was chair of wine with it was super
chill yeah it was bless yeah man we're
getting on we are going on going out is
is going overrated man yeah well when
you've been doing it for over 10 years
it's like it's gonna get old no matter
what I don't get me wrong I do like here
I do like the once in a while like I
wouldn't always love in New Year's Eve I
would always love not sporadic you know
well-known sporadic was a lot of it
before it wasn't the way when you don't
plan it what's it called
sporadic spontaneous that's the word
contain eeeh stem spontaneous nights
those I live I live on taneous and I
live for a spontaneous night yeah but
it's rarity it's a [ __ ] rarity one
Tanous nights the best night best nights
ever yeah it's it's getting it's getting
tiring man especially because obviously
I live in money and it's a uni city yeah
oh you see our uni students and it makes
you feel even that much more older he's
like ah but yeah it's it's it's low-key
just gonna be it's just gonna start
being like a dinner thing come back in
and just [ __ ] chill and I mean I'm
happy with that
I'm down on sleep I love to sleep do you
know how excited I am tonight to have a
full night's sleep
I'm gonna take my flu medication and I'm
just gonna honk out I'm physically
excited for that yeah same my chest
hurts my joints hurt
I just want to keep ah air man
want to wrap this up yeah I was gone
backwards yeah man f13 done and dusted